lows in The Meta complexity program
starting with Lee ji Chen who will tell
us about new forms of hardness
what is randomness
yeah
okay
whatever I know with randomized
algorithms so there are algorithms that
make coin choices during computation
that I only expected to be correct with
high probability
and essentially they are everywhere in
computer science and they're very useful
have thousands of applications like
female there are many books about them
this is one of them
so D randomization is the
is the process as the name suggests is
the process that converts randomized
algorithms into equivalent deterministic
algorithms and in the notation of
complexity theory is essentially asking
whether BPP the class of all problems
solvable in probabilistic polynomial
time equals P the problem solvable in
deterministic predominal time
and if this is one of the central
question in competitive Theory and has
been studied
um many years ago and uh very
interestingly a central thing in
combative theory is actually about the
connection between generalization and
hardness the hardness I mean that is
lower bounds like circular bound or some
other lower bound like uniform lower
bounds so
they are tied to interplay between these
two Notions for example a classical lab
work shows that if you assume
sufficiently strong circular bonds
you'll get a polynomial time
generalization and therefore the other
direction that another very important
network shows that for non-trivial
demolition you can actually guess like a
little bugs and the Williams even use
this to prove some unconditional lower
bounds against actually zero
but today I'm going to focus on the
first connection
so I want to take a deeper look on what
the classical Works did so essentially
they show that assuming strong enough
circular bonds can get polynomial time
generalization
and my most of my work on this direction
I follow uh motivated by two very
fundamental questions regarding the
result police classical works so if you
look carefully
what is the consequence
it's polynomial time dynamization and
the more precisely it says that all T of
end time randomized algorithms can be
converted into
the state time deterministic algorithm
for some big constant C like it's it's
not specified but it's greater than
let's say it's
so this type of optimization is
perfectly suitable for unsynor pressure
of P equals PPP but it's not enough for
any practical application because it's
still too slow so the the very natural
question how can we get better what is
the what's the right answer for the
limit of generalization can we get no
overhead at all or you will have to pay
something what's the minimum overhead so
that's the first question I was very
interested about is how fast can
generation possibility be
it's also very similar to the within the
prep within a plant work and find green
complex complexity while you care about
the actual polynomial
and the
now if you look at the second part the
first the
assumption part of the classical Works
people have assumed it's like a little
about very strong one like uh if nothing
style circuits and the
from this unfortunately can show that or
it's actually equivalent to prg's
student generators with login seed which
are enough for
randomization but unfortunately it's
notoriously hard to prove any circuit to
prove circular bound against
unrestricted circuits and currently the
best lines is 3.3.1 times and instead of
full exponential so another question is
that why the circular bonds are actually
necessary for generalization and maybe
those assumptions are just too strong
so the the second question I'm very
interested in this instruction is to
understand what is the minimum
assumption needed for generalization so
it's just like in crypto although we
know we need to make some assumptions we
want to make minimal assumption so the
same called support generalization
so let me first start with my work on
the first topic how fast can Dimension
possibly be
a lot of work with Roy cow so he will
also be speaking up he also be speaking
about similar objects similar subjects
in the next talk I think and we started
we saw that under possible harness
assumptions we eventually determine the
best possible worst case generalization
by what scripts I mean the damages to
work on every input for randomized
algorithms and a constant run as the
morning protocols and unfortunately that
will be some overhead which cannot be
avoided assuming some other kind of
assumptions from time Point complexity
so
to further reduce the overhead which
also showed that under strong very
strong highest assumptions we can
actually achieve effective
generalization of randomized algorithms
and a constant run as the modeling
protocols with no overhead
let's see a little bit more about what
effective demolition
the more precisely classical Works shows
under circular bounds you can get
dramatization with a big polymer
overhead
and I recent breaks tool by Dora Corbett
oh and Zuckerman show that on the lower
bounds against Nanny from money after
protocols you can get quadratic
generalization
and my original work with with Roy it
shows that assuming one function exist
and a lower bound against non-uniformed
algorithms which is very similar to
Circular bonds you can actually get your
imagination with an overhead of only m
surprisingly we also show that following
our work by Williams under an assumption
called shot and sdth is this overhead is
actually tight
foreign
for faster generalization
and similarly we can we also look at the
generalization of as the Merlin proof
systems where you want to dynamize into
MP
and the same story goes the classical
works so you can get big polymer
generation and my recent work with raw
is so that under strong under similar
lower bound assumption you can actually
if the number of runs goes to it's a
constant we can we also classify what's
the overhead with respect to the number
of runs again under sharp answers we
have all results are typed
so the sub ancest is also a still a
barrier for passenger Malaysia in the
in the randomized proof System case
how do we circumvent this chapter
barrier
one lesson from crypto is that if two
things are indistinguishable by
polynomial time algorithms then we can
practice say that the same thing so
inspired by this notion can we actually
show Randomness is indistinguishable
from useless by which I mean that
I guess we mean that for every job and
time randomized algorithm you want to
find an algorithm with slightly more
running time to diminish the algorithm
such that
for every polynomial time sampling about
distribution the UI algorithm is
actually it's very hard to find a
mistake so it's correct and every
polynomial time internal by distribution
except for near the probability
so in other words no efficient adversary
can break your dynamistic algorithm by
finding a mistake meaning that it's
going to be very very useful in the
practice so it's essentially solve the
problem in the practice so essentially
want to do a fine-grained version
that has been asked me
yeah and that's very important because
you can get with no overhead like it's
going to be very useful
and uh in terms of notation I'll just
write BP time Japan it's in effective
time you have earned with some with
until it's overhead
so
um understand complicated but still
possible assumption I'm not going to
Define specify it here
uh it's a it's a sound more complicated
but very proud about 100 assumption for
example you can pick F to be some
concrete hash function it's very likely
to be true you can get this effective
generalization with very small overhead
the Epsilon care can be taken to any
constant
and uh
we also achieved the same thing for
shrinking
yeah it's shrinking and uh
oh so it's uh
okay that's some complicated notion on
it so essentially saying like saying
that for each output for each output bit
you can compute the ink of end time but
it's very hard to come to the f as whole
uh in like less than cap and times and
to the Epsilon time
so it's like hard to unbox so it's like
a non-patch computable function
we also achieved the same thing for last
morning protocol under even stronger
assumptions but uh I think I already
will talk about it so I'll just go away
so one thing I want to say is that in
terms of techniques that you can
actually show that no PR this or
Blackboard generation can give you
effective organization even with that
submenial overhead let's say until at
8.99 so you really need to use something
Beyond prg and we call it non-practical
magician and uh
so what we are definitely using some
something called targeted API to but I
don't have time to Define milk
so uh how much times
Okay so
how many minutes one or two minutes okay
so previous standardization Frameworks
are based on pages
second question which is the minimal
assumption
and uh we now have previous Dimension
Frameworks are based on prgs and they
impact generalization
foreign Works shows that if you assume
uniform know about like X not equal to
BPP you can get PR that is equivalent to
appears that works on average from which
you can get every little generalization
but it's unclear whether analysis is
implied by P equals PVP but it's very
unclear whether you can get P usbp by
only your average cost periods because
they are too weak so maybe the
assumptions for for the the type of
content are just too weak so as you can
see something is missing here and that's
exactly what we are trying to
um fill in
we actually introduced a new type of
highness assumption which is which has
two-way connection between
generalization so it sits right in the
middle so it's not it's neither too
strong nor too weak
so what is the assumption
it has to have candles
so it says that remember time functions
from MP to MP that is almost all input
hard against all into a ten times
randomized algorithms so what do I mean
by almost all input hard it means that
for our but finitely many input input X
and for every entertain time randomized
algorithm it's not going to be able to
compute the Earth so it's like extremely
strong assumption saying that every 95
algorithm might fail almost all inputs
Computing F but uh but so why don't care
about is that assumption it's the best
it's actually very simple to prove that
you use PVP then this assumption is true
so it's 100 assumption that is implied
by P usbp and the proof is very very
simple just a simple diagnarization like
two lines
and then we are and of course this is
only one with only connection that it
may not be that interesting so which but
we also show that with an additional uh
constraint put on the function app you
will further assume if it's compatible
by polynomial size lock space uniform
circuits of n Square depths you can
actually you can actually get P equals
PVP
so so you will if you add some more
constraints then you can actually still
almost all input the highness is also
sufficient for generalization
so putting everything together we
actually have two weeks we have two
two-way connections between
almost unimportant harness and also P
equals PPP so in some sense it's a
suppose the rich and unnecessary for
generalization and Roy will speak more
about some other type of connection
between generalization and the
harness
and uh I'll just stop here there's some
many new ideas but I don't have time to
go through
yeah thanks
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]